again are you getting sick of it yet i'm
going to appeal
to a graphical method to understand it
and then i'm going to have to pull out
some algebra to know what the exact
value is but
maybe you'll be able to see what's going
on okay now the log graph what does a
log graph look like
as it's coincidental it's the inverse
it's the opposite
of the exponential graph there they're
sort of like you know
you know my evil twin type thing okay so
what does it look like it looks like
that
but reflected so here's the shape i'm
going to get
you'll notice i'm only drawing the
positive x
axis just like i only drew the positive
y-axis
over there and there's my log curve
okay so it's it's uh reflected across y
equals x
so here's my x equals zero asymptote
because sure enough i'm approaching that
i can never get there
this is my log base two of x
axis okay now just like i had a
y-intercept of one
here i have an x-intercept of one
here so that's what it looks like okay
i want to know when this thing is less
than three when is it less than three
okay so looking at my scale
i'm not going to be able to go up that
far let's put three here
okay let's put three there so that's
going to current
on to some point over here and it's not
inclusive
it's not included and then you can see
from here
all the way over to here i satisfy the
inequality
does that make sense so just need to
work out well what is that point
right so how do we do this to work out a
point
i work out the equivalent equation to
this right
equivalent equation sorry that's log
base 2 of x is
equal to 3. and that will find me a
point right
so that's what i've got and all i need
to do is rearrange this log equation
in terms of indices right so the bases
stay the same
2 to the power of the subject before
is the power now and x will become the
new subject
so x of course is 8 over there
and so now i have my boundaries right i
don't go past here
just like the exponential doesn't go
past here right so
i have to be greater than 0 and then i
have to be less than 8.
and there's my answer okay make sense
because by definition two things
number one anything to the power of zero
anything to the power of zero is what
for this
and therefore by implication what's the
log law that corresponds to this index
law
law base a
if you raise anything and you want to
know what power
gives you one that will always be zero
a and half naught is one right and one
is your x does that make sense
so in this case it's